what's your take on uh
them decriminalizing drugs and organ
they just drugs all drugs yeah it makes
sense
it makes sense because you fill up the
you know a lot of junkies especially in
vancouver
in vancouver you know i mean jail is a
a place to get a meal and a you know a
warm place to sleep
you know and so they don't mind being
busted
you know i mean they're junky they're
sick people yeah
you know just like be busting people
that have the the
virus well you got the virus okay lock
them up you know
it's it's a sickness and and it's worse
than the virus because it's an addiction
a significant any time you see a guy
laying in the gutter
with the needle sticking in his arm you
know that it's not his
choice of lifestyle right it's something
he has to do
thanks so much for watching this clip
and if you drink
coffee you need a mug shot
mug that's my first ever mug shot and
this mug is available on amazon as well
as at stevo.com
so go ahead and click the link in the
description below this is what you're
gonna find
and grab yourself a mug shot mug
yeah dude yeah
dude